play so that would be really useful yeah
the next one is
wait wait wait guys why don't we
what we're surfacing here is a bunch of
fairly straightforward wfr level
functions which we should just put in
there
like lose flattened cell groups thing
right wfr is a good place for these
things
you know we don't have to agonize about
the design yet yeah does that make sense
to people well the flatten as i said is
easy it's trying to go the opposite
direction i wouldn't know where to start
without running something really
complicated
i understand but if somebody can write a
wfr level function for that we've got a
place to start yep
and people can start using it
okay let's run through the next one is
really petty about i've solved it
several times by hand myself which is
there is nothing that to boxes turns
into a tag box there is no tag function
there's no constructor for tag boxes
um
so i end up writing a tag function who
has no rules except some make boxes
rules on it just so that i can use two
expressions to make things that have tag
boxes or you end up having to flip in
and out of more boxes and display and um
so there is a constructor for tag box
but i hesitate to mention it because
just just interrupt really quick donna
tells me we are streaming now
okay
i mean we are
what what does that mean we are
we are live
as of one minute
okay uh and the next one is the reverse
problem i actually put it in as a
suggestion recently is that we've got
these constructors texcel and notebook
documents alike but actually
other than throwing them at the front
end there's no way to do an equivalent
to boxes it turns out there is but it's
very obscure no and it's undocumented
so if i go to text cell and i export it
to pdf you get the word text cell
appearing everywhere you can't
say it's a notebook of this list of text
cells
um again the easy to write the pure
solution was one that i added for myself
uh because i would say this all the time
um and it's one that i've since been
telling people about but yeah perhaps we
need a dedicated
utility for this okay the next two are
just moaning uh and the last one is uh
if you actually want to make something
looks like an application
you know you can't get it's kind of hard
to suppress menus and branding and the
like to make it look like an application
so that would be nice i know i can do i
can do set options on the menu but then
you have to worry about cleaning that up
if they close the notebook and open
something else and
it'd be nice if just when this
notebook's in the foreground
the menu system was simpler gone or
wait a second i mean we have had this
plan for a while
to have
the possibility for standalone
applications of having a collection a
selection of three or four possible menu
configurations
so
uh
so i've put implementation of that
behind uh a rewrite of the
of the current menu code the the the
menu code in the front end
uh
is some of the older code that's there
and it hasn't
there are some aspects of it that
have not dated well as operating systems
have evolved
and it makes it more difficult to
implement features around
menus like this so
uh it's it's
you're right steven and it's not
forgotten but i have postponed it for
that reason
actually just popped into my head on
that one about alignment and layout this
was one i was wrestling with just this
morning i just pasted into a chat that i
didn't manage to solve
which is how to make that look nice
oh issues with baseline position yeah i
just couldn't solve it maybe i'm missing
something but
i played around with bass lines and
and alignments and i couldn't get them
on the same baseline
how does rasterize determine the
baseline of the thing that's rasterizing
well
i mean
rasterize
doesn't do i mean rasterize doesn't do
anything with base lines
i mean i mean it's creating an image and
then you're subject to the rules of you
know
if it doesn't doesn't image have a way
of specifying how it's where its
baseline should be i mean if i have an
image it does but it's not uh it's not
content rasterized does anything with
but it's not content dependent so to
speak
right
right
well that's probably the issue that
there should be some way of connecting
in the case where you're rasterizing an
expression that has a baseline there
should be some way of connecting the
baseline inside the rasterize with the
baseline that the image will be given
outside
making sense so like rasterize i mean
you know clearly rasterize this should
be straightforward to solve i think it's
just never been thought about
rasterize you just it knows what it's
been given
right
and so
so it should be able to either take the
baseline of what's been given and
grandfather that into the baseline of
the image
although i mean also that that's one end
of the problem but actually what if this
thing wasn't you didn't this was just an
image i gave you
well it's kind of feminine
see
that's the issue image has an alignment
okay so all that has to happen now i
think this is more about baseline
position not alignment point
when you're aligning it with text
as the row tries to do you can use show
right with baseline position as an
option with an image right but you need
to know what the position is oh yeah
that's true
but raster i certainly can know this i
mean rasterize takes a second argument
what is it
box
bounding box that knows where the where
the baseline is
it returns the size and the baseline
okay so the the issue is look there's a
baseline position okay
so
i don't understand this automatic why
doesn't automatic align with the what if
there's a question of what rasterize
should do if the thing inside it has a
well-defined baseline should it align
that should it should it transport that
through the image function and the
answer is surely yes
this is a question for shoddy
and
i think this is all her functionality
because it's well it's it's gonna
it's a mixture of hers and
ours because
you're you're getting that information
from the front end and and then
uh initially and then she can construct
it from there
but don't you have an easy what is the
way to find the baseline of something
from the front end uh well
so i mean actually the the
the underlying packet which is used by
rasterize returns baseline information
um i mean it returns bounds information
and that balance information includes
baseline information
what's what's the top-level function
that is the equivalent of that
well there's a top-level bounce function
but i don't think that that actually i
think that that might strip or bounding
box i guess it is uh
but i think that
uh that
might strip off uh
what is that function called developer
backtick bounding box
okay you know
we should wait a minute and oh yeah yeah
okay so i it's it which is
it's it's undocumented and it's oh oh
yes so yes it's
equivalent to rasterize with bounding
box of the second argument
and yeah so it's uh
uh
i believe
if i recall correctly it's width height
and baseline i think it is
you know we should modernize this stuff
this should return there should be a
function that returns an association
that has all of the
i mean again something we could start
off as a wfr function something that
just returns all of the typesetting
positioning information for an
expression
as an association don't you think
um
it's not unreasonable
okay
i have actually managed to do it now but
i wouldn't say it's an elegant solution
i doesn't really matter i mean the okay
fine
the
yes
okay
fine but but yes the fact you can do it
is not i mean we should have something
which simply returns for an expression
the full story of where is its baseline
where is its bounding box etc
um
makes sense
i mean that would be something for for
lou and as i say initially let's make a
wfr function although i think that
should be a system function
you know just get that with absolute
options
of what
no it's not an option
oh the baseline position in an image
size wouldn't give you the
no
um no that's that's not how baseline
position works
ian our live stream is asking
this being becoming a free-for-all of
front-end features is asking about um
would it be possible to have the output
cell displayed to the right of the input
cell with an equal sign
uh that's
i mean
so so ages ago
i posited the idea of horizontal cell
groups
which got kind of you know
fair to midland uh interest and so i
didn't pursue it
much further because there's a lot of
things got a lot more interest
yeah i mean that's related to
multi-column layout and so on
and so actually this this was an
interesting exercise i tried to write
this
using a template box that targeted the
output back on its own box structure to
update itself and i fell foul of not
being able to
target a box that was next to the box
that
was the evaluation box
so
i don't know i can't remember the
details now because this was a year ago
i had to go with this but i spent an
hour on it and and gave up because i was
struggling to figure out how to tell the
front end to write to a specific
location in a reliable way
if you kind of clicked away while it was
evaluating things like that
that that um you you you can get a
parent box
quite easily but a sibling box you can't
and and like i said this is it's you
know the whole box exploration question
is
uh
you know it requires some some real
thoughts uh
you know there's some trivial things you
can add but if you just add a bunch of
trivial things you're gonna
without thinking too much you're gonna
end up with a design that's a mess
is the story behind inline cells any
less complicated
destroy behind i don't know
if you wrapped boxes in inline cells
would it help you
navigate
using cell objects
uh cell tags possibly possible well
inline cells are a bit tricky as well
but not as tricky uh
it's it's a
um
i think it depends on what you're trying
to do um
okay given given that we're talking
about all kinds of notebook issues and
we're going to return back to the course
oh but really quickly you can't get a
parent box of a cell object
so if if a cell is an inline cell and
you get a parent box an inline cell in a
box data cell and you do parent box you
will get the box object
this is the kind of thing i really want
to be talking about here about the dom
like stuff but but let me raise another
issue so which actually edmund on a
livestream has has been
is asking the same thing that i was
wondering um it's asking about multi-tab
notebooks uh
complex multi-stage analysis without
infinite scrolling okay so here's an
issue i've run into so just the things
that i do like every day
actually using our technology
you know i generate these quite large
notebooks
and i routinely
um you know oh i i want to scroll up to
collect this definition from here and
then i'm going to scroll back down to
where i was using it blah blah blah it's
really painful doing that okay what
would make it better one thing that
would make it better you know these
notebooks that
i would say decently well organized with
section headings and things like this
so having a thing which i think might be
coming in the toolbar having a thing
where we have like we do for packages
where we've uh inventoried the section
headings and so on in a way that i can
navigate to them is that something
that's coming with a toolbar
uh
yeah my memory is a little fuzzy uh i
think so but i can't remember for sure
all right okay well that's one thing but
the problem with that is how do i go
back
that is i'm working down deep in the
notebook i've got you know 50 screens of
stuff okay i'm on screen 47 i'm not at
the very end of the notebook i'm on
screen 47
and i'm working on screen 47 and i need
to go back
and get a definition from screen 15 or
something okay
so i i successfully navigate back to
screen 15
and now i want to get back to where i
was before how do i do that
well the usual this in other systems is
you have a you have a split scroll bar
and you have a two views on the same
notebook where they scroll independently
and then you just have both of them open
you don't leave the thing you're working
on you scroll the top half of the window
to the thing you want to look at yeah
well you know hopefully those things
have gotten better over the years i i
know like 25 30 years ago when i used
those things they were super confusing
i mean maybe they maybe they're better
now
um
but yes okay so that that is a possible
solution
um
where you can
i mean john do you think that's the john
fultz do you think that's the best
solution
uh well
i it's uh i i think that people are
going to disagree about what the best
solution is uh
the
uh
uh
i mean yes
split windows is something i'm totally
in favor of it's there are some real
technical challenges to it which is why
it hasn't happened but you know totally
in favor of it um
the
uh
but you know like this notion of tab
notebooks i mean this is you know a
fairly different approach which i
imagine some people would hate not
understand and some people would love
uh and it is uh uh
it's totally consistent with what excel
does
you know in excel
uh you have one document but that
document can have multiple tabs in it uh
and
uh
and you know so each one is like a mini
document but they all can communicate
with one another
right
a cursor position rich match says a a
cursor position undo stack
uh
i that is possible i think that uh
uh
i think that that's the worst of the
solutions though i have i have tried
using
uh
systems that have cursor position on
undo uh and it is it is not as great as
it sounds
at least not in my opinion
okay and and i had good reason for
thinking i wanted it uh you know i
didn't come in thinking i was gonna hate
it uh but in the end i turned it off
www mentions uh vim-like functionality
with features like bookmarks that can
have uris
yeah so so bookmarks are another way to
solve this and and that's not an
uncommon solution
uh speaking just for myself i i find
uh i find myself uh
thinking that bookmarks are an
interesting idea and then for some
reason just completely never using them
but i may not be typical there might be
people who are very productive with
bookmarks
but so the idea with bookmarks is you
can tag a cell and you get a list of
bookmarks at the top and you can go back
to that text yeah and and and it's i
mean it's a thing that you could build
in top level right now because i mean
all you need to do is just come up with
uh you know a unique cell tag and uh and
use our current notebook locate
mechanism
right
well we should try it
i mean again this is the kind of thing
um
yeah i mean obviously
actually here's a question in when the
notebook toolbar comes into being
what is the user extensibility of that
that is if somebody wanted
i mean you know there may be
there may be features on the toolbar
which are designed to be
extensible because that's part of that
feature but uh the notion that you could
you know add widgets to the toolbar
uh
you know add another year
when the toolbar comes out the door
is really that hard it's not like just
have this area is like an attached cell
yeah it's that hard
okay
because i mean that would be okay fine i
mean i do think it should be something
on the roadmap i understand not at the
not in version one
um okay look i wanted to loop back for
people who are joining this live stream
we kind of got started in a very weird
way here because i have some internal
mistakes but but um uh i just wanted to
explain what the point of this
uh design review actually or design
discussion actually was
which is we're talking about
modernization
of things that we built in the early
1990s that were very ahead of their time
at the time
and which really we haven't looked at
that much since then and those really
have to do with as far as i'm concerned
all of the low-level notebook
programming functions the notebook
locates of this world and so on
and
um
you know
selection move and things like this
what do we think about these i mean so
they're people here who use these every
day
are they sensible are they usable should
they be done differently in modern times
we have the notion of a cell id right so
so so this is one of the things that
uh
oh
maybe about 10 years ago or something
like that i introduced the the cells
function uh which uh you know is an easy
way to get cell objects uh
and then once you have a cell object you
can you can do all kinds of operations
on it that have nothing to do with the
selection uh you know you can read it
you can overwrite it you can you know uh
copy it whatever um
but uh
the
uh
um
so first of all as we discussed maybe
not you know before the live stream
started uh some of that functionality
is not
as readily available at the box level um
all right i'm just i'm i'm just looking
at what rick uh sent through by the way
first question
i'm just gonna complain why on earth is
that arrow misaligned
i i i i don't know i mean it seems to
happen with great regularity that
particular mistake yeah it's uh
and i think it
i think it might be specific to
macintosh but i'm not for sure
it looks fine on my machine and that's
what i wrote it on so i never knew that
it was miss orlando nick
okay but but so
what you're doing here is you're
you are you just made a
toolbar that allows you to go and
search for a section
which is what i was asking for yeah and
you can tell it like what cell styles
you want to populate that menu and it
automatically updates as you had
rick how about a wfr that does this
that's what you just used that's what he
just gave you
no he didn't yeah
some extra
oh resource function oh what do you know
right sorry that was okay so the real
meat of this was in there it could have
an additional option no everything say
put it in a duck cell rick is so awesome
that he heard your request build a time
travel machine went back into the past
and did it
that's exactly what happened
hey race
okay but but
this was what you were doing here
was so if i did this
in this notebook over here
yeah that'll just give you the action
menu by itself the extra code i have
it's just to put in the dark cells i see
and do we have a way of doing that to to
push something up to that i mean because
that would also be a good thing to have
to have i mean that's the way to make a
junior toolbar so to speak it's just
doing what you did here of a notebook
put of dark cells and so on
most people will not know how to do that
set options
well
yeah
i mean
um
it is look it is the kind of thing
it is a bit of a foot gun
uh okay you know if you do something
terrible we will let you do the terrible
thing and so one might argue that set
options
or current value is sort of the right
level of you know if we made it so
easy and top level that that you could
just kind of you know
uh you know drop anything on it then
people will and
and they'll make huge mistakes
well look at that with bob is sending
through a thing which does exactly what
i'm saying well lou made it i'll let him
take credit
i was just digging up the copy it looks
like bob beat me
yeah okay
um
all right
fair enough i mean and maybe these
things need to get better documented and
so i i guess i just haven't used these
things because i'm
uh
maybe we should put them in the notebook
programming guide page
for example yes but maybe we as as links
to wfr functions right but look i want
to come back to the real focus that i
wanted to have here which was
uh
you know
you've got a notebook you want to do
things with it so what john has said is
that his cells function
now wouldn't it be nice if there was
like an image of the cell here or
something like that is that plausible
it's plausible i'm not sure it's
desirable um
what if there was a button that you
clicked that selected it
uh oh that was that works
those are all buttons
i've never done that before that's cool
uh it but but the the reason i question
this desirability is
because
uh
there there are so many performance
issues around that i mean you know oh it
got its thumbnail and then you went and
changed it and the thumbnail is out of
sync or generating the thumbnails you
know for a hundred cell objects takes
takes two seconds yeah okay
fair enough i get the point i mean
it might be nice
yeah
i mean maybe there should be an option
to cells to do that i don't know and i
mean i mean you know i think the better
thing would be to have a thumbnail
function that you can wrap around a cell
object and get a thumbnail
yes that will be very reasonable i mean
we do have a thumbnail function it
doesn't do that
but it but it probably could quite
easily
right that's a good suggestion okay but
let's let's look at what we have here so
any given cell object here let's take
that cell object there
um what do i do with this now for
example if i say input form of that
oh my gosh
so if i save that to a file i'm totally
and by the way that that that input form
is
so the input form really should contain
an expression uuid and
it did in 12 3
we we retracted it in in 13 because uh
there were some issues with the
expression uuids that we
still were
we're coming up more frequently than we
were comfortable with we couldn't get
them all fixed but it will for thirteen
one again
uh so in 13 1 it will be a stable
expression uid
okay and what's it going to do okay fine
so then if i
if
if i sell expression you have to
notebook read it
so if i say notebook read
of that
well not
i didn't know whether input form wrapped
around it would go away or not it looks
like it did no it does yay okay
um
okay
so
um
okay first point is when there is a uuid
here
like many of these other things that
says this isn't stored in the notebook
so to speak
well now i'm confused here if you save
the notebook and reopen
that uuid it's it's not a kernel-related
uuid in any way it's a pure
notebook-related uuid so that uid will
remain valid if you close the notebook
and open it again correct right right
exactly correct uh the problem we have
though is that there are a few cases
where
uh
cells with the given expression uid can
get duplicated
and not have the uuid uh uh changed and
and so for you know a common example for
example is uh if you are looking at two
revisions of the same notebook in a git
repository
yes um and uh
there are it turned out there were more
of these i mean you know that one is
pretty easy to grok but it turns out
there are more of these instances that
we hadn't anticipated uh
that were coming up and we and we needed
to solve the expression uuid conflict uh
uh
you know possibilities so
and
we're working on that that's uh that's
the question is when does when is it
unique is that the question right well
it i mean you know the thing is you
might end up having to to make a
decision about uh there's actually two
of these in the system and i need to
make a decision about which one i should
which one is the best one um
so this is the thing that i've always
claimed will end the universe is when
the uuids start to collide
but but they didn't collide because they
were generated and coincidentally equal
they they collided because they were
you know went through a duplicative
process that happened outside our
product i do love this it's at least
it's at least nice to know that all
these things are incredibly i mean that
issue of it's like atoms of space get
duplicated and they have the same uuid
and then they can combine and they
cannot and so on it it it's all yeah so
it is so so basically what's going to
happen is you know the cell object will
have
uh both an expression uuid and an
instance uuid and
and we'll be able to determine like for
example if you're requesting an
expression uid from a given notebook
then obviously the instance in that same
notebook ought to be preferred uh
you know if if there are more of them
but you have no hierarchy i mean if it's
an instance uuid it's just like oh it's
a different uid that's all you know
yeah
okay
and it doesn't have a provenance
id or something like that
i could imagine a both a uuid
and some kind of
you know like dollar session id is in a
sense of provenance right right and uh
uh of course i mean it can't be session
id so
i don't remember what the current
proposal is using we're still kind of
reviewing the proposal but this is you
know it's basically just more complexity
than we had anticipated it created a
number of bugs in twelve three about you
know probably about half the two-thirds
of which we fixed but the the remaining
bits were really difficult to crack
without solving this problem
okay
okay
so okay but i want to come back to
um okay we've got the cells function
but you know like for example and and
and you know take a look at the
documentation for cells because you know
it's uh
you know i mean
it's kind of kind of like notebook
import
you know it uh
it has a number of selection criteria
you know open the details and options
and you know
these selection criteria you know these
these are useful
are you trying to make notebook import
work on cell objects or notebook
evaluate
uh notebook evaluate
they think does work on cell objects i
think i think just notebook objects
okay well it that's that could be done
it's not a big deal um so if i take if i
take that
there
and i say notebook evaluate what would
you expect happens
uh
i would expect uh i would expect it to
return
the result of evaluating
uh because it's it's not you don't have
the insert in place or whatever the name
of the option is so it should actually
return the result of evaluating that
okay
because notebook evaluate is is a bit
like calling get you know it it returns
what it evaluates
right
okay but i'm still you know when it
comes to selection move and all these
kinds of things i feel helpless using
those things yeah well and you know in
general
so like
uh you know our internal docutools was
was built from the ground up using
selection move to do everything
and boy i i wish we could you know go
back and and fix all that there are a
number of places where that yeah i see
it actually moving the curse yes exactly
that's just crazy
there are a number of places where that
doesn't have to be done anymore it could
be replaced with you know more
uh modern idioms but but that hasn't
been done so let me just understand so
fundamentally the notebook is a tree
structure
and
that's right one
you know with trees right now we have
the notion of part numbers
and we also potentially have we we don't
have
named do we have we don't have named
tree branches do we we don't have
associations probably nobody here knows
i've heard discussions uh kind of
fiddling around the edges of this but
nothing that i'm aware of
we certainly could have that and maybe
we even discussed that in the design of
trees that is when tree
has sub trees i mean if i make a random
tree
do you want me to get a trees person
um i'm not sure let me just um
okay so what you see here is that the
sub trees are in lists here
i think i think there is a possibility
that we could have an association there
but and for example when we convert h
xml
to a meaningful format it will be
converted to a tree format
so one question is
um you know well well so i mean in the
context of trees if you knew
that all of those labels were unique
which of course isn't required you know
by tree but if you knew all of them were
unique
uh then you could uh
build some operations um
around using the labels as you know as
identifying the nodes right so
and of course we can do that in the
front end with expression uuids okay so
hold on the two clear structures so in a
you know a tree is not by its nature
content addressable a graph is
if there is a node with a certain name
and a graph
then that will be that node with name x
and anything
that goes you know that points to x
points to that particular node different
from a tree okay i i didn't realize that
property of graph so that's uh yeah
right that's how a graph works is that
it just has its nodes have names and
they define you know you can't have two
nodes named x it makes sense now that
you're saying it i just hadn't thought
about it right
but but now i don't know what um
you know if i say x goes just just to to
highlight this if i say x goes to y y
goes to x
x goes to y
that will draw a graph with two edges
going the same to the same place right
right um
okay so now
what does that mean i mean for example
the fact that we now have a trees
system
see we've got several functions even
even this kind of thing which i find
utterly unreadable
i mean what would happen if i said to
this
um
i assume i can say tree form i've never
i don't think i've ever done it
sure
of that yeah
and it's mildly useful but it will be
more useful if there were more serious
illusion possibilities
i mean that is mildly useful though
if it was yeah if it had more religion a
bit more useful
um
but the point you're making is within
the notebook
okay
so
first point is the notebook is a
hierarchical structure defined by itself
groups
right
uh
well
not just by sell groups what else is it
defined by well well i mean it's uh
uh
okay so
yeah i mean it's you know cell groups to
cells to
uh
and and then you know the the whatever
the data type is box data or text data
and then
i mean you know
and then each of those can
you know have their own subtypes and
wrap back around the cell again
um
you know you can cut cells inside of
cells inside of cells
fair enough but the at the top level the
notebook
when you haven't gone through roblox
layers of roboxes the top level of the
notebook is a bunch of cell groups
i mean yes at the at the extracellular
level so to speak yeah we're dealing
with uh so
so so a serialized notebook
is uh
you know its first argument is a list
uh and the and the sec and and then it
may have options for you know subsequent
arguments but his first argument is a
list and that list may contain one or
more
cells or cell groups
right
okay but but i mean the the the the cell
groups aren't necessary you could it
could be a flat list of cells it does
not impose a cell group that you don't
need
right i mean like this notebook here if
i were to say how do i get that
expression right now in here
um
yeah
what do i do notebook get the get of no
arguments will give you the evaluation
notebook
okay
so that's the raw boxes of this notebook
yep
okay
that's interesting that was a
that there
is
why is that showing up in this form so
right um
this output you're looking at is the
standard form rendering of the boxes
somewhere in that box structure is a is
a treat call to tree form which gets
typeset
um
in the output
and that's why all the colors are
showing up as little color boxes too if
you want to see the actual you know
input form then you would you would ask
for notebook gets left i'm very confused
about why those colors are not color
boxes and these colors are
i am too
okay
um
but okay so this is the raw expression
now the question is
i'm so confused what what the
the issue is once i have that expression
i picked it up i edit it right so for
example i could say reverse presumably i
could say this
um
i could say so yeah notebook
uh notebook put at reverse at you know
i'm gonna do this
first of that reverse
that notebook put
now it only reverses the top level list
of course
so
yeah
okay but but now one feature of this is
this is a very immutable kind of
operation i picked up the notebook i did
something to it i
i output it now the only difference is
that that this rebel
is a notebook to notebook rebel as
opposed to an in-notebook rebel right
right no you're you're exactly correct
there are two kinds of when when you're
talking about transformations there are
two kinds of ways you can imagine doing
transformations one is you serialize
the thing that you want and then you
work on the serialized form as a
standard symbolic expression uh you know
doing anything you would normally do in
the language the other
is that you grab references
to the actual bits in the notebook and
these references are notebook object
cell object box object
and once you have a reference then there
are all kinds of operations you can do
with those references
okay but so so the thing i'm trying to
understand is the first you know
you know notebook programming
okay
you know style number one
immutable
basically
get a notebook object
uh do things to it no no get a notebook
expression
not an object expression right right
you're right get a notebook expression
do things to it
then hydrate it yeah
okay so now the things that are
know we don't have great utilities i
think for dealing with notebook
expressions
i mean you know just as we don't have
great utilities for dealing with xml and
so on
um
that's one thing i think another
an another thing is
you know for example we have cell print
and okay
what's what is the best
symbolic description of a notebook
okay so so let's say i mean this is the
thing that drives me crazy a bunch so
let's say i say notebook
put
and let's say i want to make a notebook
a notebook of
now i start going you know cell group of
and then i've got weird nonsense you
know hello you know
except of course you've already done it
wrong because you don't know all the
details in arcana of the
you know
of of of the inside of a notebook
expression
what did i get wrong
uh so it's uh
uh
a cell group is always wrapped in cells
and and and it's actually cell group
data as opposed to cell group
um
well okay so so that's one question is
is can we make something because i mean
some aspects of this are nice like the
notebook part of it is nice but then you
get into arcana
right and and i know that we have tried
to by by calling that cell group data
we
and by you know just like we have the
difference between row
and um
you know which is a row box
which it has is has more arcana so to
speak and needs this for example right
it can't just have a raw expression in
it
am i correct
uh
right
so yeah there are a few places where
actually people have been able to slip
raw expressions into it and that it
broke later because uh
uh because it was never supposed to work
in the first place and we occasionally
get bug reports of that sort
okay how do i make this live
cloud is particularly good at finding
things like this yeah
because because we we implement it as
john tells us and
we have to we have to argue with people
about stuff that desktop allows and we
don't support so
anyway
right okay so so
i mean the good news about boxes is you
can sort of do anything with them and
they're low level and they don't kind of
um they're not
uh you know
they don't have structure you don't need
the bad news is they're pretty obscure
that a fair characterization i mean in
other words we've got the difference in
row which is a pretty user level thing
which one uses all the time and robox
which i use only very you know i use
that only in desperation
right and and and that's that you know
that's probably correct i mean you know
row is
you can think of it as this is not 100
accurate but you can think of it as a
robox generator
but
when you're dealing with raw row boxes
one of the real dangers that comes up is
that
robox as constructed by the front end is
the end result of parsing your input
and the front end
if when it reads row boxes
uh it kind of assumes that that was
parsed correctly
and then we'll send it to the kernel
that way
uh i mean if you if you type around it
then it will fix itself but if you don't
you know i mean that would be a lot of
wasted effort to kind of force
everything to re-parse no no we don't
but that has consequences okay so look
the first style of programming is
immutable
and the main thing we don't have really
well done at this point is
a okay so the issues are
um you know
issue
a
good symbolic notebook generator
we're close
but there's you know
25 years later we need to smooth that
out a bit
does that make sense i mean so it isn't
you know the mystery of cell group data
and i'm sure this is quite easy
to solve this i think we're really close
on this one yeah well we've done much of
the work already
yeah so i mean so that's just cosmetic
okay now the next question is
um
you know the next question is what do
you do
dealing with
the
uh you know notebook trees you know what
are the operations it's it's you know
what are the things you typically want
to do
to that notebook tree
i mean a lot of what i tend to do is i
use notebook import i read it into my
own favorite you know pretty elementary
data structure i do transformations on
it and then i do not book put
but it often takes me some fussing
around to remember these kinds of issues
so we should fix that but what other
operations do we need in dealing with
notebook trees and they may be other
kinds of tree matching operations and
our new tree functionality may have
already provided them
i mean so there's a question mark here
with um uh you know does the existing
tree functionality
uh
you know
uh work well with this
because you know what we might naturally
do is to have a notebook import that
this is an interesting idea a notebook
import that imports into a tree
see what i'm saying
lou do you i mean you know
does that make sense to you
i understand what you're asking um
[Music]
i forget if the design of notebook
import allows us to return things other
than lists
i'm not sure either but it might also be
that we want notebook you know tree
import or something
well
and and
you know i mean i don't know our tree
functionality very well do we have
you know
kind of you know the algebra the
operations around it for that to be an
interesting thing
if we don't we should have
i mean you know for example you know can
i you know clip a subtree from one
position and insert it into into another
position
that's a good question i don't know the
answer but we should be able to that is
the goal of the tree functionality is to
let one do that
so it's like reattach a tree
a sub tree in a different place
yeah
i wonder if instead of notebook import
it should just be import
like could be the element i mean if
you're talking about the whole file yeah
possibly i
that this is a detail but okay so look
this is one style of programming i think
we should have one meeting about this
and i think there's a you know i think
there is
i consider this
reasonably straight path
because i think we kind of
you know i mean as i say the goal is
clean away to symbolically make a
notebook then a way to manipulate the
expression
preferably in whatever form is the clean
notebook representation without the
craft
so that makes sense
so i don't know quite what that is
that is the you know the but perhaps
that's a function that takes a notebook
and returns the clean notebook
expression
somehow with certain cleaning functions
that remove you know cell change times
or other other craft so it would be
lossy
it might be a lot easier because because
because there are many operations for
which i mean look look here's a routine
thing that i'd like to do i've got
data
in a notebook where i where it is a
mixture between human effort of me
editing things like i just did something
yesterday
where i mean as it turns out it worked
just fine i was editing a grid box a
grid right i just had i had a bunch of
data i wanted to change a bunch of
things i just you know edited the grid
worked beautifully actually and then i
re-evaluate the grid to make use of it
if that makes sense
um
but in a more complicated case i would
like to do that with a notebook and that
is in a sense for if i want to do that
repeatedly that's what a form notebook
is for
i mean you know good example i don't
know i've got um
uh
yeah i mean okay here's an example that
came up we got a list of um
uh bibliographic
citations
of the nks book thousands and thousands
of thousands of them okay
and there are things where
they're in a notebook and
we
wanted to like do some programmatic work
on them then we wanted to by hand
rearrange pieces of them and so on
it's like how do you do that
and
a reasonable way to do it is you just
notebook import the thing and i couldn't
care less whether it has its cell change
time data preserved and all that kind of
thing yeah
there
um but i do want it to be the case that
for example let's say i'm searching for
duplicates
um you know i want it to be the case
that that's easy to do and i'm not
having to worry about all kinds of craft
with um you know oh there isn't a
duplicate because it's got a cell uuid
hanging around and so on
does that make sense in other words it's
the i want to get the content of the
notebook
well well the uh uh you you're never
going to get the uuid because that's uh
you are making a copy and when when
you're when when you're making a copy
the uuid does not come along with all
right okay good all right let's talk
about style number two mutable
okay
and including self-mutation but both
both quotes self-mutation
and remote control mutation
if you understand what i'm saying
yeah i
i'm not convinced that they're
really
there's really an interesting difference
between the two okay but remote control
mutation okay so okay so the other point
here is
uh sort of referring to notebooks okay
so i can say notebooks open close
and i've got things like that
um
and this is okay this mechanism i think
works okay i mean what i tend to do when
i'm using these is i literally copy
paste one
is that is that what you would expect me
to do
uh
that's quite reasonable okay
and i mean you know so i'm i'm
reasonably happy with this mechanism but
now i've got in a sense remote control
mutation
so for example i'm not seeing it if i do
in this
if i do a notebook you know locate
whatever i'll present i can obviously do
a notebook import on this that's the
immutable strategy
right so this is
but then
if i want to like let's say
i want cells on that
okay
and um
all right so let's say i wanted to know
okay so let's say i want to do something
on this let's say i want to know the
cell change times
how would i do that
uh
so
current value
of the cell object comma cell change
times
okay so current value
cell change times it's listable so you
can just give it the whole list if you
want
why isn't cell change times
because cell change times is a symbol
not a string
and why is that
current value should just take
okay i mean again these cell change
times the fact that they're displayed in
absolute time is a is a feature of the
1990s or something
well
i mean
for it to display as anything else we
would have to store it as something else
why
i mean you're asking to display what the
right hand side of cell change times is
the right hand side is uh is a machine
real
okay okay fine but i mean and what i'm
saying is that
this is an example of not very
user-friendly
stuff i mean because this this would be
you know if i say
what is it from
what is it called is it you know from
absolute time uh
okay
really
that seems bizarre and interesting okay
um it's in uh utc i think
those numbers
no i understand the fact that 2018 and
2022 yeah no that that
that's interesting
maybe you cop
you must have copied and pasted them
yeah yeah that's this notebook here
that's this notebook and these things
here were created in 2018
it's the sample notebook and some of the
samples were created in 2018. yeah yeah
but
so unlike expression uuids the cell
change times does travel along with
copies
right why are there so many cells that
don't have a cell change time
um
[Music]
isn't that an option that might be
turned off for you yeah i mean so this
was uh sorry where did this notebook
come from again it was some example data
notebook that rick brought in well so it
may be that the people who created the
just turned it off
yeah okay in any case but but we're
talking now about mutable work on a
notebook so this is move this move the
selection you know write something at
that selection i have never understood
how to do that stuff
um
what is what is the modern way of doing
that you know so so the modern way to do
is to don't do anything with selections
you know the only reason do something
with selections is if you're pretending
to be the user
right so in other words okay so the
principle is
the selection
is just
sort of quotes dis you know it's just
user it's just fluff
and it isn't
well let me be clear there is a valid
user case or sorry there is a valid uh
case for pretending to be the user and
that is for example
uh if you want a palette button
that makes a change
that the user is going to click on and
they expect it to operate on their
selection so there are cases where
that's what you want to do
uh
but also you might want to move the
selection you might want to do something
where you help the user by up you know
by activating a particular input field
right but but in all of those cases they
should you know the reason you're doing
it should be because you're just giving
the user more interactivity that you're
extending their level of interactivity
it's not because
you know you should never be moving the
selection around because you're just
processing notebooks you should be
moving the selection around because
you're you gave the user kind of more
interactive you know uh features
right
okay it's just for
for
user masquerading
uh
you know activities so to speak yeah
yeah okay but so other than that
how are you expecting you know let's say
i want to go in i mean this is
a um
uh
this is very reminiscent of a problem we
have never solved which is you've got a
graphic
okay so okay okay so there are two kinds
of transformations that you might want
to make
uh one is you might want to
uh actually change the content of
say a cell object uh if if you want to
you know if you want to change the
content then really you just have to
read it transform it and write it back
if you uh the other possibility is that
you might want to change
uh the uh the options uh or the styling
in some way and with that you can use
current value as the left-hand side or
set options
okay so you're saying you're saying
uh
changes to a cell basically yeah um so
so if for example you know copy one of
those cell objects and and do
you know uh
current value of the cell object
comma background close bracket equals
red
like this yeah yeah
my god
and of course set options does the same
thing just with a different kind of
syntax
wow
okay
i mean i guess i knew that worked this
we do this kind of thing a lot the that
sort of transformation
incredibly useful
and it's lightweight too it's uh
you know
it
it doesn't matter how complex the thing
inside that cell object is making that
transformation is is trivial in terms of
computation
sure but what this is doing i mean like
for example the thing you just did
if i have a graphic
you know i say graphics of you know disc
and then another disc you know
[Music]
there is no way okay so i've got this
there is no analogous thing i can do
that says pick up that disc and make it
red
uh
not
easily
why no there isn't i mean so
it is possible
to get if you can get a box object
corresponding to that disk then yes you
can do
exactly what you're saying but getting
your hands on the box object is
not there's no documented way to do it
and the undocumented ways are a bit
challenging
yeah i mean it's kind of absurd what we
would have to do is some kind of i don't
even know if you can do it if i if i
said insert
there and i can't even find out what
this is another thing that i would find
useful is what part number you know what
part number is that how do i find that
out
well and in fact
you know it's uh
the the the part number
might not be
a 100 predictable from your input as
well
so yes
um
and and so one way one can imagine doing
this and this is what john mentioned
earlier is uh
uh box ids
do this and and you can
you can assign a box id to any box
uh and then we have an undocumented api
for
uh being able to
get the box object from the box id
all right
so we should wrap up in a second here
but but um
this is a second topic right mutability
and i'm going to claim that we need to
think about mutability for other kinds
of expressions as well and that whatever
mutability i mean the fact that this
worked
is kind of bizarre and scary to me i
mean
it's bizarre you know set options is an
immutable i mean if i do set options
i see that's not that also isn't
immutable
i mean that's also another mutable thing
there if i take that
and i say set options of that
um
background arrow pink
let's go watch it over here
okay it does its thing
um
wow
so it's like an assignment i mean you
know normally in the system there is one
set of things that is assignable to and
that symbols
what you're saying is that they're also
these
objects
i mean in a sense we are beginning to
have that with some of the data
structure stuff that we have
of expression did we ever finish that
that functionality of expression objects
did that am i misremembering
is that a thing
no we never did it
do you remember remember expression
objects um
not
readily
okay they are mutable expression pieces
that was the idea and i guess we never
finished that design
i mean i think we've looked at this
multiple times over the last like 15
years
um
yeah i see an expression object ild
folder for you i also see cloud
expression object
in reference pages
cloud expression object
the cloud expression is a
there's a thing what's this
um
by the way i by the way i thought i was
that's from way back when we're talking
about getting trees from the notebook i
was gonna say it's sort of an inverse of
that
but that's interesting because that's a
representation
that's part of this discussion here of a
way to
represent a notebook
in as clean away as possible
the heck is that
okay so what you're doing is it's an
alternative to having sort of easy to
use function names here and
you are providing another lower level
specification for a notebook
that is also programmatically
specifiable right the main purpose of
this was really just a way to visualize
a big association of data
um
rather than be just be able to construct
arbitrary notebooks it's really just
meant for i see
associations but it okay so this is
expression browsing
in notebooks
four associations okay we've got a whole
bunch more to discuss along these lines
multiple uh uh branch meetings i think
from this um i have to go to another
meeting for those who are following
these live streams this will be about
multi-computation
um actually i see ali has some comments
here which i just want to look at um
uh
saying this is this is the notebook
free-for-all this is smooth scrolling
for heavier notebooks yeah you know i i
was using our product
um
last couple of days and i discovered
that i had a nine gigabyte front end
hanging around i didn't really know it
was a nine gigabyte front head nothing
much seemed to be going wrong and i had
notebooks where i looked at how big they
are and there's like oh actually that
notebook is three quarters of a gigabyte
and to me
the um now the only you know the reason
we end up with three quarters of the
gigabyte notebooks is because everything
is in the notebook we don't have remote
assets um and arguably that's a mistake
but it is impressive that we can deal
with that and have it be quite smooth
so i mean the only way we would do
better is to have remote assets with
asynchronous loading i think
um
the second comment from ali is small
image of the current notebook showing
what objects to expect further down
um i have to say that one thing i have
found really nice
is you know we have our physics
the this is the
mini map um
so
we've you know mini map is a
scroll bar mini map style scroll bar is
on a road map
okay
this is remarkably nice
this is an auto generated thing these
are cloud notebooks
they're you know whatever they are
they're there well okay that's a well
that was from literally yesterday you
know it's auto generated here
and um
uh you know this is now a notebook that
was saved to the cloud
and um and that it has some heuristic
for deciding you know the image to put
up here i find this really useful i mean
this was intended for other people to
look at but i find it more useful to
look at this than i do to look at my
file browser
andy's here he made it
okay good for andy
but i mean the do are we providing this
for other people
this kind of functionality i've taken a
directory full of notebooks
and visualize it like this
i don't think so but i think we could
wouldn't be hard yeah
it's really nice seems like function
repository sort of uh candidate
right
yeah because i think andy you're using
html templates even so
yes
yep
right okay ali had one more comment
um i i i i'm a bit mystified by this
comment i should say
a quick function that actually aborts
all computation without crashes
so
uh
the the uh the quit menu item
is generally pretty robust uh
so
i'm i'm kind of interested in the search
are we talking about quit colonel or we
talking about quit the whole show
quick kernel
okay so uh now now you know
i've found that that's robust as well
yeah i mean now if the front end is so
hung that you can't get to the menus of
course that's a problem uh but uh
you know if you can get to the menus and
get to that command my experience has
been uh you know you might end up with a
zombie kernel if the colonel's in a
really terrible state but the front end
will you know will walk away from it
um
and usually pretty robustly but you know
maybe there's something we don't know
and i'm i'm happy to to see reports on
it so
right sounds good okay
well i have we have to wrap up now but i
think we need to
we have several different things we've
got the immutable part which we need to
look at i mean i think these are the
things that i wanted to concentrate on
with these uh you know specific notebook
programming
pieces of functionality and we need to
follow up for those
all right okay um okay so
thanks and um
bye for now and for those following
these live streams we'll start another
one in a few minutes